[موسيقى]
البيتكوين الايثيريوم البي ان بي
والكاردانو وغيرها اسماء متعدده ترمز
لعملات رقميه جعلت العالم منقسما بين مرحب
مقتنع بباب الاستثمار المالي الالكتروني
الجديد ومشكك ببديل قادم تندثر معه البنوك
التقليديه فما القصه
[موسيقى]
في 8 نيات القرن الماضي ومع انتشار
استخدامات الحواسيب خشي الكثير من
المبرمجين من قدره التقنيه الجديده على
الحد من الخصوصيه الفرديه فقاموا بوضع
تصور لحمايه بيانات المستخدمين بقياده
اريك هيوز الذي فنده في كتاب بعنوان
بيانك الذي يخدم رؤيه مستقبليه لاتصالات
مشفره وامنه جاءت من ضمنها عمله رقميه
تسمح بتداول الاموال بسريه
في عام
1989 انشا عالم التشفير الامريكي ديفيد
شيوم الديجيكاش لتكون اول عمله رقميه
واعتمد تقنيه بلايند سيجنتشر اي تعاميه
التوقيع بحيث يتم اخفاء معلومات التداول
وضمان خصوصيه المتعاملين
في وقت مماثل ضغط مالك المتاجر الهولندي
على عدد من البنوك لايجاد طريقه شراء
الكترونيه فبدا العمل على انظمه البيع
الالكترونيه التي اعتبرت احد اقدم الامثله
على النقد الالكتروني المرتبط بالعملات
الرقميه الحاليه
في عام
1997 اطلق جيمس وايجل برنامج اعاده ارسال
البريد المشفر التي عرفت بسيفر بانكس
سي دي ار وكانت الخطوه الاولى نحو نظام
اتصالات حره بعد فتره وجيزه انشا شخص يحمل
لقب
على الانترنت النظام النقديه مجهول الهويه
بماني الذي عمل بطريقه مشابهه لعمل
البيتكوين اليوم لكنه افتقد لاليه تحفظ
الحسابات بشكل لا مركزي في عام
1998 ومع ظهور التجاره الالكترونيه فضل
المتعاملون الكشف عن هوياتهم واستخدموا
بطاقات الائتمان فتراجعت اهميه العملات
الرقميه واعلنت شركه ديجي كاش افلاسها
بعد نحو عقد من الصمت شهد عام 2008 ظهور
البيتكوين التي انشاها رجل الاعمال
الاسترالي كريج رايت تحت اسم مستعار هو
ساتوشي ناكاموتو لتصبح اول عمله رقميه في
العالم
ورغم ان اسمه بقي سرا حتى عام 2016 كان
كريج واضحا في نواياه عندما اراد ان يلغي
مفهوم البنك التقليدي ويجعل جميع
المعاملات مباشره بين المستخدمين
تميزت البيتكوين بعده خصائص مثل قابليه
النقل والندره والمتانه وقابليه التبادل
وقابليه القسمه وامكانيه التعرف عليها
وظهرت كبديل استثمار المال بدلا من شراء
المعادن الثمينه كالفضه والذهب او العملات
الورقيه فنمت وكسبت ثقه كبيره لتصبح ما هي
عليه اليوم
في عام 2009 ابرمت الصفقه الاولى لعمله
البيتكوين وكانت بين ساتوشينا كاموتو
وهالفيني بقيمه 100 بيتكوين حيث تم
الاعلان عن انشاء موقع جديد ونشر النسخه
الاولى من برنامج بي تو بي فاونديشن وبدء
التداول بين هذه العمله مع الدولار وكان
البيتكوين الواحد يبلغ واحدا بالالف من
الدولار
في عام 2015 ظهرت عملات جديده وهي لايت
كوين والايثيريوم وجمعت 75 مليون دولار
قبل ان تطرح شركه فيسبوك عملتها الخاصه
بها ليبرا في عام 2020 اليوم وبعد اكثر من
ثلاثه عقود على اطلاق اول عمله رقميه باتت
العملات الرقميه اكثر تداولا وثقه عند
الكثير من المتعاملين حول العالم حيث تجري
العديد من البلدان ابحاث امكانيه اعتماد
العملات الرقميه بشكل رسمي فيما يقف القسم
الاخر مترقبا ومتريثا قبل خوض التجربه
واقتحام هذا العالم
[موسيقى]